[Musique]
des images surréalistes celle d'un
commissariat attaqué par des tirs de
mortiers d'articles cela s'est passé
cette nuit juste avant minuit à
champigny sur marne en banlieue parité
l'eau lorsqu'ils ont vu les 40 individus
se diriger vers eux ils ont juste le
temps de s'enfermer dans le sas et après
ça a été un déferlement de violence
qu'il ya une partie d'entre eux soyons
clairs là aussi sans ne sont pas
français immédiatement quand ça lui
chante ça j'en sais pas ce qui vous
permet de le dire pour l'instant on n'a
pas de nouvelles informations sur la
nationalité des personnes qui ont
attaqué ce commissariat
donc j'ai dit une partie hockey à vous
avez donc des informations dont nous ne
disposons pas mais si vous avez très
bien le droit de penser qu'une partie
d'accord c'est une supputation
une information dont la solution elles
existent et elles doivent passer par un
tour de vis absolument considérable sur
la criminalité
je suis frappé de ce gouvernement qui ne
cesse de faire des tweets de
condamnation à chaque fois qu'il ya des
événements qui se déroulaient qui sont
de plus en plus grave est en réalité
rien n'est fait vous êtes dans le déni
permanent mais c'est vrai c'est pas ça
que je suis là lorsque j'aurai une
journaliste je suis journaliste on parle
d'informations
monsieur mariani jeune journaliste on
parle d'informations vous supposez les
voilà d'inuits leur dit que c'est une
supposition
on a libéré des milliers de prisonniers
pendant le coc vide ces milliers de
prisonniers en fin de peine 1 il était
enfin devenu enfin il était quand même
en prison nous c'est ce qu'il faut avoir
fait pour être en prison ferme
aujourd'hui en france avec tous les
aménagements de peine qui permettent de
ne pas y aller donc aujourd'hui qu'on
vous libérer les prisonniers vous
libérer des multirécidivistes très
souvent et ces multirécidivistes on est
en train de les retrouver aujourd'hui
dans la rue je pense qu'il faut qu'il y
ait désormais clairement des peines
planchers pour le premier acte commis à
l'égard de dépositaire de l'autorité
publique
moi ce qui me frappe le plus c'est le
discours moralisateur du gouvernement
qui tend à faire porter sur les français
le poids de la responsabilité d'une
crise que malgré tout il faut le dire
les autorités publiques morali
on parlait du nombre de lits depuis mars
par un lit supplémentaire mais alors
juste gouverner c'est prévoir et
gouverner c'est prévenir la question
c'est qu'a fait le gouvernement depuis
sept ans nous avions cinq mille lits
disponibles il y en a autant aujourd'hui
en ile de france il ya même moins de
lits de réanimation disponible
aujourd'hui qu'il y en a fait en mars
pour les lits de réanimation puisque
c'est le sujet qui nous préoccupe et il
y a eu échange assume une part il y a eu
à défaut de prévoyance pouvait-on
imaginer qu'ils auraient à virus c'est
autre chose mais c'est vrai que moi je
pense que ce qui a manqué dans toutes
les périodes j'ai compris la mienne
c'est de la souplesse sur les masques si
on en avait dès le mois de mars ne
serait probablement pas dans la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes et
nous aurions probablement pas été
obligée de confinés durant deux mois que
les conséquences terribles sur le plan
économique comme les stocks n'ont pas
été renouvelés le gouvernement en
l'occurrence était celui d'edouard
philippe a dû constater qu'une partie de
ces masques n'était plus utilisable et
plutôt que de le dire parce que ça peut
arriver et de dire non nous n'avons pas
à notre disposition suffisamment de
masques
protégez-vous d'une autre façon mais
mettait une une forme de protection ce
qui n'a pas été dit un défilé militaire
sans demi-mesure à la gloire du régime
et sans mesure tout court sur le plan
sanitaire
pas de masque pas de distanciation le
75e anniversaire du parti au pouvoir ne
défie pas seulement les nations ennemies
mais aussi la pandémie de coronavirus je
veux que vous sachiez que notre nation
va vaincre ce terrible virus chinois
nous produisons des terrains pied des
médicaments puissants nous guérissons
les malades
nous allons nous en remettre et le
vaccin va arriver très très vite
je tiens à le dire sans faute je
remercie les nord coréens pour leur
bonne santé
aucun d'entre eux
on a été victime du virus malfaisants